the speaker for today is Abu Sheikh Abu
Sheikh manages the engineering team
building the Q flow platform and
supports the mission of Q flow to make
scaleable ml models in deploying them to
production as simple as possible he
originally worked with Google search on
crawl and indexing systems and then
spent few years with enterprise ml
startups before he returned back to
cloudy a platform and is now in the
working on Q flow I wish Sheikh take it
away thank you for attention welcome
guys thank you for showing up and also
apologize for the little bit of delay we
had but we'll start and I think Sean
through already kind of gave me ain't
about like how to communicate with the
audience I would like to be a bit
interactive if possible and I might ask
you a few questions on the way and okay
I think the first thing we are all here
probably when we talk about machine
learning what do we want to really do
the first thing that comes to mind is we
want to build a model how many of you
are data scientists or consider
themselves data scientists I see one
that is lower than what I expected
I'm sure there are more data scientist
here anybody else how many of you are
engineers or people who productionize
models okay a bit bigger group great
thank you I'm sure you have all had
different experiences doing this but
everybody has probably phased this you
start with thinking that you are going
to be building a model and the moment
you start doing actual work you realize
well there's a lot of other stuff you
have to do around before you can even
get your hands on tensor flow or
something to train your model you start
with data ingestion you have to figure
out where to get data into your system
from data analysis leader transformation
validation actually creating test sets
training sets then training a model
building a model experiment a lot of it
and then then you want to validate your
model figure out whether it actually
does what you are looking for and after
that you want to train at scale roll out
the model in production if it doesn't go
into production I don't know why it's
worth to tree in the model at all so I
think that is probably the most
important step and then actually survey
and build probably an application around
it of course then eventually you want to
monitor and have logging as well so
what's the problem in this in this
workflow or in this space
setting up an ml stack that a or a
pipeline is incredibly hard anybody who
has done this I think would agree with
me that when you start doing this you
realize you need to install a lot of
tools either on your desktop workstation
wherever you're working you get sucked
into a lot of engineering and DevOps
where you need to install get things
connected working together to figure out
networking and I don't know what not
talk to production engineers and doing
this on production environment is even
harder it's you have to be careful
you're not messing things up that are
already there
if you productionize your model in the
wrong way you might end up with making
completely wrong predictions from what
the data scientists intended when they
actually train the model and is setting
up an ml stack that works across
different clouds or different
deployments is extremely hard in fact I
don't know how if it at all is possible
in current with the current set of tools
and for our current purposes for today's
discussion we will consider your local
laptop or your desktop to be multi cloud
as well it's just another instance of
the cloud alright if we look at our
experimentation stack when you are
building your model your training
locally trying things out you have a lot
of stuff running on your laptop and
enabling you starting with hardware at
the bottom with accelerators operating
system drivers run time and then storage
and on top of this you have your
frameworks that you actually use to
train and bail your models on top of the
stack on your laptop or your desktop
you're going to be installing a bunch of
micro services that enable you to
compose and create your workflow all the
way from reading and data training and
then testing out your model making
predictions now we take it a step
further you gotta do this whole thing
over and again when you actually want to
train your model at scale we all would
love to train the models with the volume
of data that we
available the more dealers it's the more
data points you were able to use
hopefully we could you get better
accuracy in your model and then finally
you actually want to deploy your model
on to cloud we're actually the N
endpoints are accessible to users and
they're actually making difference in
the real world actual intention of your
model for all three of these
environments unfortunately right now in
the current set of technologies that are
available you have to literally redo a
lot of this stuff what you did in your
experimentation stack to actually build
your model is not exactly what you can
take to production or to or deploy on
the cloud and there's a ton of work
involved in making that happen which is
why we thought of building cube flow and
we started this effort our mission
literally is to make it easy for
everyone to develop deploy and manage
portable distributed ml on communities
so in in summary essentially the
platform is going to allow you to run
cube flow wherever you can run
kubernetes on whatever cluster whatever
cloud whether it's on Prem or some kind
of cloud platform if you can run
kubernetes on it you can deploy a cube
flow on it and take your technology
stack along with it including your local
machine so you can you can run
kubernetes on your local machines as
well with this technology essentially
this is what your stack should look like
you are literally working with cube flow
services and whatever you deploy and
develop you should be able to translate
it across all the environments without
much effort looking at what what's going
on inside cube flow we have a bunch of
micro services that we rely on in
building our ml workflows and we have
integrated a whole bunch of components
some coming from Google itself from
tensorflow T effects and others from
open source community including things
like TF transform dump ice power for
data transformations TF data for data
validation Jupiter for actually a
development environment where you
experiment and build your model TF job
and extent by touch to actually train
your model at scale and T of serving
cell don't answer our D for serving
at scale with with the kind of latencies
you want and from matthias were
monitoring there is more stuff that we
can't fit on the slide but also there is
even notice there are boxes which are
right now missing component so we do
need to kind of like build out more
components and get community to get
involved and incorporate their solutions
into the platform alright so that was
kind of the back story and what cue flow
is about and like how it kind of like
lets you translate your solutions across
different platforms I want you to spend
some time on this slide and think about
like what the user experience is going
to look like people who have done
development of models we want to kind of
like see what is the workflow you will
be going through when you are trying to
figure out how you develop and build
your model one of the important goals of
cube flow is really creating a low bar
and high ceiling experience what do I
mean by high ceiling if you notice the
way cube flow is designed on top of
kubernetes it's it does not restrict any
kubernetes level api's and in any every
tool that is available on cue flow you
should be able to configure to your
heart's content and in whatever
environment you are there is a lot of
complexity in enterprise world a lot of
challenging networking setup and
different kind of environments that you
might have to optimize for and the
configurations in queue flow should
allow you to be able to go down in the
detail and modify whatever it is that
you need to make it work in your
environment but on the other hand we
want to enable users who are not
familiar with kubernetes to be able to
access this platform and be able to
build their ml flows without having to
worry about learning communities
similarly on the redesigns front-end as
well I mean there are engineers who are
just starting learning data signs they
have a lot of good background in
communities and systems but they might
not be that familiar with data science
we want to enable create a low bar for
them as well have tools that will enable
them to to build data science machine
learning products without having to go
too much into detail of learning various
technologies if possible okay with that
in mind
I would like to present an example which
will walk us through the user process
that we just user experience that we
just talked about it's specifically
focusing I think a lot of you are
already familiar with water github issue
is generally if you go to github I think
there is a content associated with with
the actual issue where you have all the
details and then you label you title the
github issue with a title that seems to
fit or describe summarize what the issue
is all about the problem we are going to
be looking at is essentially a user
filing your bug and when they are
running into some issue they are not in
the right mindset and they are really
troubled about what's going on and all
they want is like to pace that error
provide whatever information you want to
provide and then file the issue that
might not be the best time to think
about what exactly is going on and what
should the real title for the for the
bug be so with that in mind one of the
real scientists at github
actually thought about this problem and
felt that he can come up with an FML
algorithm or animal model that will look
at the content analyze it and hopefully
suggest a title that is relevant and
they're helpful so I want to thank at
this point ml from github who actually
built this model and Uncas and Michelle
helped productionize this into an
application on top of cube flow and
while I'm at the stage of thanking
people I should also thank a whole lot
of other people none of the the content
that you're seeing is actually my
creation it's a lot of people who have
actually had created and I personally
really want to thank Jeremy who was
around actually right here you should
please meet him when you can he's our
tech lead of Google Q flow engineering
team and he conceptualized formulated
the idea around Q flow starting in 2017
and then in December 2017 and how's this
to the world along with a product
manager David Aaron chick who's not here
today but he's also one of the fun so
the two of them co-founded this project
and really defined the vision and the
technology that will go into making this
happen and to this day we rely heavily
on them to provide us the direction I
would also like to thank Google's Q flow
engineering team
now them none of this would be possible
and of course the cue flow community we
really love our community they are
extremely inviting open friendly and
they helped us a lot with figuring out
solutions to these problems all right
moving forward the step first step that
we were talking about in the user
experience was deployment and this is
something really fresh actually this is
not directly available so far but I want
to give you a preview of like what
deployment experience would look like
with this application that we have been
building and this this deployment is a
deployment of cube flow on top of google
kubernetes engine as I mentioned you can
deploy cube flow wherever kubernetes
deploys whether it's Microsoft Azure AWS
or some other cloud or your on-time
hardware but we are specifically
focusing in this presentation on GK
based deployment you start with a few
set of fields you talk about providing
information about the Google project
cloud project that you want to deploy
the the stack on and a give the
deployment and name and then provide
some kind of authorization information
and then be able to say click deployment
and a few minutes later you should have
you should be able to view your cluster
along with the services running on your
kubernetes engine dashboard so what this
is showing a sorry about the small font
but essentially these are some of the
core services that cube Flo deploys on
your cluster when you create the
deployment a lot of these are
fundamental to stitching together your
workflows or your your process to train
or deploy a model the URL here that you
are looking at is essentially a way to
get into an access point into your du
flow cluster deployment everything by
default the way it is deployed is is
predicted in your cloud project and not
accessible form from an external IP with
the exception that we create this
ingress point which has a IP protection
Google IP protection that allows you to
access and authorize any access that is
going into the cluster so if you click
on that link it takes you to the Q flow
dashboard right now it's very minimal
and we are working on figuring out what
is the right information that should go
in here and what all make sense but at
this point it kind of like helps you
bounce off to a few things that you are
most commonly going to be doing the four
thing that it will help you get to is
the Jupiter hub which is where you will
be actually doing a development and that
is the next step in the in the
deployment process I do want to take
some time here and look at referring
back to a principle that we talked about
of low bar high ceiling we created the
UI web UI bass-driven deployment process
to lower the bar on deployment to make
it easy for data scientists who are not
familiar with communities to get on to
Google cloud and be able to create their
cue flow clusters without much effort
just a few clicks and a few keystrokes
but on the other hand we want to ensure
that anybody who's familiar with what's
going on has complete control on what
their deployment is going to look like
so on that front
this CLI base deployment uses calf
cattle which is our command line tool
and it lets you control your deployment
with four sets of commands in it
generate apply and delete we see an
example of how that workflow goes for
deployment on the right side so you
start with initializing your deployment
it ends up like reading a few parameters
and environment variables determining
what York like on figuration is going to
look like and then creates an
environment variable and in its indirect
tree which is going to be your cue flow
application referring to your cue flow
deployment once that is done then you
can and in this instance again is
appointed to a GCP google cloud platform
so it will end up creating a GK cluster
the next step is basically generating
the platform and what that generate does
is it generates a lot of configuration
about what is your what your GK
configuration is going to look like the
benefit of this is that that generated
set of configuration is available
locally from where you are doing
deployment and you have access to that
configuration you can go look in there
browse around what's going on and you
are able to tweak a lot of stuff and
modify things if you want to create
additional load pools you want to add
GPUs right from the beginning or you can
make a lot of configuration changes in
there whether you want to have IEP or
not essentially and the next step is
going to be apply the platform which
would actually take the configuration
that it generated in the previous step
and then actually talk to Google deploy
a cloud deployment manager and create
the GK cluster that that was defined by
the configuration
the next step is going to generate the
kate's about which are basically
configuration for the various services
that will deploy it on your gk cluster
so in one of the previous slides when we
looked at the gk cluster it had a list
of services that are running as part of
coal queue flow those the configuration
for those services is generated by this
command and apply would again go ahead
and apply that but intermediates if it
allows you to keep that configuration
available and modify in whatever form
you feel is needed switching back to the
Jupiter notebook you go to the Jupiter
hub and this is the page you land on
which allows you to create a Jupiter
notebook if you notice here the first
field in here is letting you choose a
container image we have a few pre-built
container images these are docker
container images which already have
tensorflow support for different
versions of tensorflow a long way the
image is built for CPU or GPU if you
want you can just click spawn at that
point and then say like start my
notebook but it also allows you to
configure further and specify how many
cores you want so if you know your
workload is going to require GP you can
go ahead and specify that you need GPU
containers and then you can specify how
much memory you might need once you have
created your notebook you're inside the
notebook and this is kind of your
playground review you go around you can
import tensorflow libraries if you are
working with some other Python libraries
by touch you should be able to pip
install packages here as well and then
you have access to those packages Python
packages you have access to pandas
whatever whatever other Python tools you
might want to use this is where you will
spend a lot of time iterating through
your model figuring out what works what
doesn't work and how do you want your
model to look like connecting to various
leader and and actually training your
model remember that at this stage you
are still running inside your your
container that has got the jupiter
notebook running so you're you're only
working possibly with a reasonably sized
data set that will allow you to iterate
and experiment on your model once you
have figured out what your training
script is going to look like the next
step in the process is to build
docker container image currently the
process involves defining docker file
which will specify warrior' docker
container needs to have installed so for
example if you need to install a few
Python packages you will have
corresponding pipe installs in there and
then you copy in your training script
python script that you had from your
notebook you can create a corresponding
Python file and you can include it in
your in your container image along with
any other supporting libraries you might
have written that you want in there and
once you have specified the docker file
then you will use docker build command
to build the docker container image and
then g-cloud to push it to cloud from
where you can actually then use the
container image to create your training
jobs another thing I do want to call out
here is looking back at the low power
high ceiling I think for but for a few
data scientists this might be too much
they might not want
they are probably capable of doing this
but is this where they should be
spending most of their time which is why
we are thinking of integrating this into
a workflow that goes directly from the
notebook and you are able to take your
training exercise and from there itself
click on build and then at the back of
this it will actually create a container
image for you so there are different
ways we are thinking of based on the
feedback we are getting or now we can
lower the bar at every step alright so
let's look at the next step which is the
most exciting part for me at least is to
take my training script and actually run
it on a distributed crystal
train a full-scale tensor flow model in
any application that you deploy in aq
flow cluster we the way it works is and
I will go a bit more in detail in the in
a few more slides but essentially it
involves generally two steps creating a
configuration for your training job or
any other service that you want to
deploy on your cluster and then
essentially making sure that you have
that configurations parameters specified
appropriately based on what you need
like how many workers you might need
where the models input is going to come
from where do you want the output model
to go and they're setting up sizes on
what what your training set is going to
look like maybe possibly
once you have your configuration ready
then you can kick off your training job
by saying take this TF job configuration
that we just defined and apply it on my
cue flow cluster and that's the key a
supply command which actually takes the
configuration then talks to the cluster
and says bring these bring up these
containers get it running and while that
job is running you would be able to use
various cubicle commands to monitor the
pods that are running the job to x-axis
the logs and figure out what what is
going on with the training job back to
the same I keep coming back to the same
theme but essentially looking back at lo
see low bar high ceiling we do want to
allow data scientists or anybody who
actually just want a bit of flexibility
and ease to be able to go and create
their tensor flow job configuration from
a UI and this is really possible because
if we look at the previous slide there
was a lot of configuration which is
defined for the job and we can literally
interpret it pause the underlying
configuration and generate the UI
corresponding to that configuration and
allow you to set the parameters not from
the command line but from them from the
UI and here you you should be able to
like point to the container image that
you want to use how many workers you
want to use and where where to pull the
data from etc great once our morale is
strained the next step for us is how do
we serve this model i I believe the
example that I present here is to kind
of use tensor flow serving and you could
use Selden as well which is available in
cube flow and we have a github examples
repo that you can go and take a look at
for the github issue summarizing for the
github issue summarization example and
then you should be able to look and like
see how that the same thing can be done
using Selden in this slide I will walk
you through tensorflow
serving to you to serve the model we
talked about this case case solid that
we use I want to give you a bit of
background on what's going on over there
we use case on it which is a
configuration language which allows
templating to describe various
configuration and the power of
templating
to parameterize a whole bunch of things
that you can specify and set and modify
your configuration at the time of
instance instantiation so all queue flow
components are described by a
corresponding K solid configuration
which is available to you on your in the
audio configuration directory that you
created when you were deploying the
cluster from there you should be able to
create services by generating new
service components using the template
and then configure the parameters as I
am doing here we generated a server
inception component which is a brand new
component from the T of serving template
and then we are setting a few parameters
here talking about like whether we want
an HTTP proxy do we want to use GPUs
where the model is actually going to be
sold where to load the model from and
there are a bunch of other parameters
that I'm not using but you should you're
free to explore and figure out what you
want to configure and then the next last
step just like last time is once your
configuration is already you say KS
apply and then it will actually end up
deploying this component on the cluster
and bringing up your model finally
deploying a web app around this is a
very similar process you would end up
probably using flake or some other
Python library or whatever is your
favorite tool to kind of build every bap
against the server the the model that we
just created and once your application
is ready you can create a corresponding
container image deploy the container on
cue flow and then you have your UI to
talk to your model at the back I think
I've been mentioning this over and over
but essentially that is the real theme
here is that we have been working on
making sure that we get the BRIT of the
components that are necessary across the
whole spectrum of the workflow all the
way from data ingestion to deploying and
running your applications there's a lot
of work around this more than we can
handle by ourselves which is why we are
relying a lot on our community to
provide us solutions as well and we
would encourage you to get involved as
well but while we work on this bread we
do study our users and get a lot of
feedback and
figure out where they are having
challenges and we will leverage that
information to drive lowering the bar
and improving the experience on on where
wherever we see there is pain in user
experience we have tremendous momentum I
think since the project went went live
early this year late last year early
this year we have over thousand plus
commits now 100 plus community members
that are active and roughly 20 plus
companies that are contributing and you
can get live stats about this from our
github repo finally I do want to mention
queue flow is open we are an open
community we love people joining our
community and contributing open design
open source and we are open to ideas
which is why we are hoping that more and
more data scientists get involved as I
noticed today area there are very few
inner scientist I would love for you to
go to our website queue floret or go to
our github repo file issues let's start
there why don't you file issues on what
what is not working not working for you
and then we'll get you more involved and
hopefully you will have ideas to
contribute happy to take some questions
if you guys have Thank You Chuck
what one question I had earlier we
talked about different companies
creating their own ml pipelines and
things like that
Uber's Michaelangelo Facebook's FB
Lerner how generalizable are you guys
designing this and do you think that
this could potentially apply to the use
cases they have and how are you guys
kind of optimizing between being
opinionated and and being more general
right I think we're starting from a
place where we are not opinionated and
we want to allow the flexibility and
allow the community to kind of come up
with ideas and contribute I think the
biggest challenge at the beginning is to
kind of get the breadth and make sure
that we have components we have support
to cover the whole end-to-end workflow I
think one of the biggest challenges if
people are interested is data connectors
this is a big pain point for all
enterprise solutions where people always
ask us like can we can we have
characters to our data systems and
similarly I think you mentioned
Michelangelo face
all of them have various strengths and I
think we are welcoming them to come and
contribute it to the Oasis community and
build it into the platform we would love
to have that not only those if anybody
else wants to build we have a lot of
contributors who have gone and like made
their fort to take their components but
make them available and we would
encourage to continue to do that
thank you Hey
thank you for the talk so one of the
issues or one of the things that can
help better scientists today is to to
know what the standard way of doing ml
is because there is none why and how to
do feature engineering how to do serving
order training and if we are doing it in
a way that it is compliant with the
enterprise's then being opinionated
actually helps absolutely so how do you
how do you see this right I'm not
disagreeing I think your question is
very valid and I do hear this from a lot
of customers we talked to a lot of them
are at a place where they are tell me
one way to do this and this that is what
I want to do I don't want to explore and
figure out so we do see a spectrum of
people where there are really
sophisticated engineers and teams that
are actually they want full control but
there are people who are actually
interested in like this is my business
problem that is what I want to focus on
and just tell me how to kind of like do
this I do see a time when opinion being
opinionated would help but I feel like
the at the beginning of the project it
is not the right time to form opinions
where we won't even know what the right
opinions are I think it is time for us
to kind of explore and allow the
community to contribute ideas along with
us producing ideas as well and hopefully
we find out from our users from
customers what works for them we are
willing to help them set up when they
are confused or if they need some
hand-holding and guidance we are willing
to put the effort our whole community is
happy to do that in providing guidance
but I think I I don't believe that if we
start being open ated right now I think
we will end up losing some good
solutions and we might end up creating a
platform that is not usable by all I
think the whole ml space in my opinion
is at a place where as an industry we
don't really know what the right way to
do all the things are and we need
figure that out first before we can
start imposing those opinions on people
good evening my name is Paul thank you
for the information it seems like a
really great tool to help a lot of
people thank you I'm I've been hearing a
lot about key stores and I'm curious how
q flow would play with like like key
stores or managing identities okay I
know that you have like I am in the
Google Cloud right platform
can you speak to that right I think we
are relying for identity and identity
and access management to be on the
underlying cloud platforms for example
queue flow itself is not reinventing the
wheel on a lot of like underlying cloud
infrastructure so on on Google cloud we
rely completely on in fact we will rely
heavily on kubernetes to design and
define those solutions and leverage that
and in addition to that when you deploy
kubernetes on different cloud providers
if they will be leveraging the I am
solutions that that might be available
over there does that make sense yes
thank you thank you Paul I was wondering
if we could help us position queue flow
against some of those managed machine
learning platforms and how you see it
from the Google perspective right I
think it will be a good idea to do that
there are definitely users as we just
discussed who can benefit from managed
services as well and I think it's an
important part of their experience where
they are willing to experiment and go
deep into certain areas but there are
portions of the ML workflow where they
would not want to invest and it will be
create to integrate I think that also
ties into the question that mark I think
about like how do we get FB Lerner or
for example Michelangelo or maybe Google
clouds managed offerings to integrate
into the platform I think it is
important for us for us to figure out
integration points with those services
for example people might be willing to
spend time and are are okay with things
failing or experimentation going on in
training phase but the moral leverage
the strength
of Google simile platform for serving or
similarly there could be other managed
services that might be providing so I
think that's an interesting idea and
very useful as well we should definitely
look at all those solutions as well I
would not discount any of those does
that answer your question
cool thanks Vanessa you mention at the
beginning that oh boy um not only on the
cloud but also on other clusters right a
new currently deal with other kind of
cluster systems like HPC systems right
that's a good question
so I think I mean we rely heavily on
kubernetes to provide us but provide us
the capabilities on deploying on
different platform and on Prem is for
example one such platform where we are
working with certain partners who are
focusing on making this work to work on
like high performance clusters for
example if there are infinite band
connects or if there are other kind of
interconnects that for example Cisco SMI
high bandwidth connections as well so we
would rely on some of our community
partners to help us port these platforms
on to those hardware platforms is this
currently still not available right I'm
not aware of this but I do know that for
example certain certain of partners are
working on the solution right but this
is certainly something that we are
interested in thank you thanks ok thank
you thank you
[Music]